pues este proceso inicia en un contexto
particularmente complicado para matteo
salvini desde hace ya meses desde que
inició el gobierno actual dirigido por
mario draghi y apoyado por una gran
coalición que incluye el partido de
matteo salvini la liga pero también el
partido demócrata de ezentis
centroizquierda y el movimiento cinco
estrellas antisistema en este gobierno
matteo salvini ha tenido dificultad a
imponerse un gobierno que ha
deshecho varias de las medidas que albín
hizo aprobar en el pasado cuando fue
ministro y en los últimos meses todo
esto ha jugado a favor del partido de
extrema derecha hermanos de italia quien
ha superado a la liga en las encuestas
nacionales y para completar durante las
últimas elecciones municipales aquí en
italia a inicios de octubre pues los
candidatos de la liga perdieron estas
elecciones y todos estos pues son
factores que han debilitado mucho a
matteo salvini políticamente